[Music]
julian and dad it's good to have you
guys here
hey we're pretty happy to be here in
nashville talking about this yeah
pleasure
julian
hello elusive peterson
finally cornered into a podcast i know
ed yeah
it's been a lot it takes a lot of work
to corner him a lot of work i think yeah
i don't know if this was cornering i
think yeah the least cornerable peterson
yeah
yeah that might be saying something
who's the most cornerable peterson
elliot
[Laughter]
for now for now for now yeah
definitely yeah
okay so today
yeah it's not my dad
it's not your dad no no
yeah
okay it's not scarlet no
it's elliot
hi so today we're going to talk about
essay
mainly and then i'm also going to throw
in some questions because i think people
are dying to know
i relate everything about you
good luck
okay julian
yes
why did it take you so long to agree to
talk to me over the interweb
um
well i'd like
i like my privacy i've always liked my
privacy but i think that's most of it i
don't really have a lot of interest in
being a public person
um
if i
am public in
any way then
i generally
well i'm quite sure that i prefer it to
be about something that i've done
and i didn't really feel like i had done
anything
that was particularly
you know useful let's say to talk about
to other people um and so
you know i i have a really nice life and
i like my little family and my um
you know the fact that it's
relatively contained from from the world
and you know i don't really ever want to
give that up but
i do have interest in sharing things
that i've done that i feel like are
going to be meaningful for
for other people whether that
is
well this application which i'm really
proud of or
um
well
the album that i released last year i
didn't really talk about that um we're
gonna talk about that
but i think that's why mostly is i i'm
you want to wait till you had something
to say yeah
yeah well the problem in your position
is that
people would be interested in you in
some sense for peripheral reasons for
sure yeah you could certainly yeah for
sure
and and
you could say that demand if you felt
like it but it seems to me that waiting
until you have something i don't feel
like it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah no kidding yeah and it's
been good to see that your life has been
protected from all the storms that have
gathered around us and that that was a
good decision i think
so and this is a good thing to talk
about because this app is
could help a lot of people yeah well and
then we should talk a little bit about
testing too one of the things i realized
years ago and and had
drummed into my head as well by people
who have built successful software
programs and marketed them is that you
should be in dialogue with your audience
your customer base let's say while
you're building it you don't build
something and then launch it and hope
everyone buys it you have to be testing
it step by step with the
market with the environment
to see if
not only do you have the ideas right but
you have them right at the right time in
a way that can be communicated to people
that they will want to purchase and will
purchase and so you tested this
with actin academy for example yeah yeah
so we tested this with like a number of
different groups over the last couple
years um
with private groups on reddit with
people who signed up to test it with
peop with students
mba students at the actin academy
um
using
usertesting.com
groups you know we tested it constantly
as we were as we were building it to
make sure that our design was consistent
that people understood what it was for
um and many times they didn't
which is well often what you find when
you test software um yeah well you
get you get familiar with it
and then you think it's obvious because
it's now obvious to you but it's
interesting watching people often use a
piece of software that you've designed
and see
where they don't get it yeah isn't that
what they did with uh
one of the first macintosh computers
right they uh
they would bring grandmothers i think
people over 60 to to come in and they
would just put them in front of an apple
computer right
and
you know not tell them anything they
would just like use this thing yeah and
you know they'd pick up the keyboard and
like do all sorts of stuff with it and
figure it out they tried to find it
sometimes
right they did they do all sorts of
things right but that was that was how
they did the testing right either either
you're supposed to give people a task or
you just want to see they naturally
interact with it um and we did we did
both of those things and and
you made a lot of improvements you have
to be aware of the assumption that
um
people should be smart enough to know
how to use this it's like no
if they can't use it because it's a
stupid design
if people were just a little smarter
they could figure this out it's like
yeah good luck no that's how you fail
yeah that's how you sell your product to
three software engineers
yeah exactly and yeah they want to use
it just because they want to show a
smart thing yeah
no that's a very bad design philosophy
it's if if someone can't use it it's
your fault
it's the right
attitude in business that's why it's not
so much
it's like websites when every single
website has a formula and looks the same
and one other website is oh no no that
logo or that button should go in this
other corner yeah one that's the modern
internet right like is is that
everything looks the same because well
then people can use it right you build
in redundancy yeah and and yeah and you
violate conventions at your apparel you
know we could have insisted that
everybody use a dvorak keyboard for this
writing program and that's a way more
efficient
keyboard because the
letters the alphabet letters are spaced
for optimal speed when you type but you
don't see people using dvorak keyboards
well one of our developers did yeah what
what is this type of i was nodding along
like i knew what you were talking about
but i don't there's a keyboard that's
more effective oh way more effective
yeah well yeah because
at least
we're not telling you about it because
you have to keep learning using qwerty
the qwerty keyboard was developed at
least in part to slow you down when you
type because yeah for typewriters right
with the old mechanical typewriters
before electric typewriters the keys
would jam if people got too fast
so they slowed them down yeah so now we
use a keyboard that artificially makes
typing so what's the other one look like
the most common letters are together or
where they should be yeah like on a
qwerty keyboard the most common letters
are spaced out as much as they can be
because i can type really i'm very proud
of my typing i can type really fast yeah
but do you think it would be worth a fun
stop
because people people would be a
struggle at the beginning yeah yeah
that's right you'd have to re-automatize
your but yeah yes yes it would be faster
eventually yeah would it save me time if
you add up all the time
and then yes i'm doing it yeah i think
it would but can you buy computers like
that like macbooks you can buy keyboards
like that you can't buy that right you'd
have to have a separate keyboard what's
the what's this called dvorak is one
d-v-o-r-a-k
yeah just rings off the tongue you know
yeah
yeah
okay i'm going to ask some fun questions
too
are you ready it's going to involve
julian talking a bunch
hopefully
okay
shifts uncomfortably in history
i'm actually not that worried about that
hopefully you'll do that on purpose if
it happens
yeah uh what has been the biggest
challenge of having dad
shoot to fame
yeah well there's been
a ton of challenges benefits and
challenges um
i think mostly
there's a couple things you know it it
gets you involved
in
a battle that isn't your own which is
interesting right because of the way
that
that you became
popular which was about you know
political topics and philosophical
topics that were contentious generally
um
and so then people start to assume
that
you know you hold the same opinions as
your father
which to a certain extent i do obviously
right like i mean there's some things
that uh and plenty of things that we're
aligned on and but there's always you
know you never have the same views as
your father i mean if you do then you
need to think more probably because well
your generationally different in all
sorts of things
yeah that's what every father thinks
yeah
essay program
so that was one of the challenges and
and
well just
being
being public to a certain extent you
know people know who i am even if i have
maintained relatively private um i've
been asked for selfies before which is
very strange because
i'm just a regular dude
that's that's a selfie with us yeah yeah
oh yeah well your approach to that i
think has been interesting you know
people people get random like free guy
reference i think
keep up man this is a quick moving
conversation
so one of the things that's been that
your situation has really um highlighted
for me
is the danger
that's posed to people's
mental health and maybe even to social
stability when people get fixated on
things that are too abstract and you say
well we should only pay attention to the
important issues climate change for
example which is about everything why
aren't you worried about everything all
the time and that's what you would be
worried about if you're a good person
it's like
well no
you need to parcel off a part of your
life that's private that consists of the
specific things that you're involved in
your specific wife your specific
children the specific projects like this
always like to be referred to that way
and this is my specific wife
don't ask me any more questions
but it's a strange thing because you
could be more concerned with generic
wives than actually having one you know
yeah so and you you've you've maintained
that specificity and that's made your
life
comparably much more peaceful and yes
that's for sure yeah so
it's easy to get dragged out into the
general fray and it's hard to protect
yourself once that's happened
so
okay here's another one so
when
how old were you when you got married to
jail
25
and then when did you have elliott
26 i guess yeah yeah okay so i'd say
compared to 37 maybe general
debaucherous population yes you've
even compared to me
definitely compared to me
you've had your you've
organized your life
so
it from the outside anyway so well
that it's hard it's hard to believe
well thank you that's a really nice
compliment you went to university you
got a bunch of educate what was your
what did you do in university i did a
bachelor of arts which everyone thinks
is the best thing to do yeah that's uh
no but i did i did a cool one it was uh
i went to university of kings college in
in nova scotia and i recommended places
yeah great university and did a great
books program called the foundation year
program um
there's a one-year program where you
read kind of the history of great
western thought yeah
and so i did that to begin with and then
i did my general degree in philosophy
uh and music
and you wrote your thesis on heidegger
and the psychedelic experience yeah
that's right yes but that was a common
topic among students yeah
yeah yeah yeah well yeah yeah you know
one of the things that's interesting i
worked with a lot of
high-performing lawyers and this was
especially true of the women they were
hyper conscientious and they were
overachievers
which is a horrible word
in
junior high and in high school it's two
words
no it's one word it can be it can be
hyphenated anyways
they were the top of their high school
class then they were the top of their
undergraduate class then they went to
law school and they were the top of
their class and then they got picked up
by a big law firm and they shot up
through the ranks and became senior
partners it's one word
no wait no
and then when they got to be senior
partners they generally concluded that
they didn't want to work 60 hours a week
like all these other guys and although
they were women and
they wanted a more balanced life but
they had never really stepped outside of
this single-minded track you know and it
wasn't until they hit the pinnacle of
what they were aiming at that they sort
of woke up and realized well maybe this
isn't what i wanted to be doing all
along
and
the interesting difference with you i
think is that
well you've been organizing your life in
a pretty consistent manner and in a
traditional manner i would say
you've also
pursued your artistic pursuits
simultaneously and that makes it
different because
that's a place where you can have
freedom
within the context of discipline and
where those things actually work very
well together you told me that we were
walking the dog in the park like a
couple months ago and you're like what
you know what do you want for yourself
in five years and i was like well i want
to have
you know a good family life and i want
to have a career that's meaningful and
you know good generic answers but you
were like
oh so you have feminine goals
i guess yeah
yeah well
well that should that fits very well
with the story yes
the high achieving woman yeah
yeah well that could be worse
yeah no i'm happy about it i wasn't
offended i just think it was a little
surprising 40. well i mean time will
tell yeah
well if you do please keep that private
well yeah
i would be keeping that private
anyway um my point was i guess
do you have advice for
younger people about how to like are you
happy that you're settled down now with
a kid and yeah for sure there's
no i wouldn't really have it freedoms or
anything well yeah obviously in some
ways it's limited freedoms um
but
well i feel like when you get into your
late 20s
or even mid-20s you've probably been
partying and
doing random stuff and living with
roommates for
quite a few years already you know i
mean it it doesn't
i don't think it remains interesting for
that long and even with
you know people i know that are around
the same age
everyone at around this age or not
everyone but a lot of people end up
settling down to a certain extent and
whether that's you know
it's needing a change of some kind
whether it's deciding to travel the
world or switch careers or go back to
school or something you can't just stay
on the same kind of young person
schedule forever
and
well i found someone who i fell in love
with and
i always was attracted to
women who wanted a family and i always i
was one of the family and so it it fit
in well for me and i think that's fairly
uncommon with young women you think do
you mean one of my observations of you i
know you were very private so i don't
know all the details thank god is that
you tended to mostly have
long-term
pretty committed relationships yeah
and do you know that was the case with
me too generally speaking
do you think that was associated with
this conscious desire to have a family
i don't even know if it was i think that
i'd well i normally just chose women
girls that i liked
would you want to go out with a girl
who's like i hate children that's super
attractive
i never want to be like i'm just that
just shouts infertile
yeah well it's not so bad if you don't
want children and if you only regard
them as an impediment but if you're
shouting it that's definitely a problem
yeah that's a problem yeah yeah if
you're shouting that on the street
probably you should be there avoid it
but i don't know it was just it's just
kind of how it worked out for me and and
um oh i was really lucky you know i met
someone who i was extremely compatible
with
very young
and our relationship is only improved
with time how did you know
how did you know that that was gonna
work out well i didn't and we had ups
and downs right like we
well
yeah we had our ups and downs and i
didn't i yeah i didn't know until really
until
we were married i guess weirdly enough
like maybe not
well maybe yeah maybe that's fairly
normal but but even when we were engaged
you know i feel like
we were still kind of feeling each other
out to see if it was really the right
path
um
and you know we went through
growing pains and all sorts of things
that that all couples go through we
fought a lot at times and
but the the thing that i guess made me
realize that it was
you know a relationship that was built
to last was that every time we did our
relationship improved um right and then
it was happening less and less whether
you fight it's whether you reconcile
yeah for sure that's what it's all about
right it's all about finding someone
that is willing to put in the effort to
improve the relationship
you know over the years because people
change and their needs change and their
interests change and you have to have a
partner that's willing to
listen and
and keep up with you
right
are you good at negotiating
yeah i'd say so i mean that's one of the
things that we practiced a lot as kids
right and that was one of the things
that made our childhood somewhat unique
i would say was that we spent a lot of
time being taught to negotiate and so
yeah it's definitely one of my
one of the skills that i'm
that's very useful in relationships i
guess that i have
and useful in other ways no
we did i started
a curse leaps to mind
when you
have arguments and negotiate
we had a podcast
last year with an fbi negotiator
and his
take was that
you either agree to something and the
other person kind of meets you there
but you don't meet in the middle
what's your take on that like when you
guys have disagreements are there things
where you're like okay i'll give a
little and she'll give a little and then
yeah i think eventually that's what
happens but i think that when you i
think it's a hegelian synthesis
yeah i also don't know what that means
well
how do you know antithesis
right synthesis okay not negotiated
metal yeah okay okay yeah that's that's
what i was going to say obviously i was
going to use exactly the same words too
yeah were you yeah
and there's no way of knowing that i
wasn't going to
um but yeah basically you know i feel
like one person has to basically
give in a little bit at the beginning
and then and then the other person will
meet you somewhere along the way
eventually once once the once the
negativity or the emotion goes out of
the situation
right i think it's very uncommon that
people reconcile at exactly the same
time
right it's almost always one person
decides that it's
you know either understands what they've
done to contribute or is willing to put
that aside in order for
you know to have a real communication
with the other person um and then you
know and then once the once the emotion
comes down and
and people can see more clearly then you
meet somewhere down the road i guess
down the road yeah well i think that
initial willingness to give in
isn't that it's
i'm willing to change as a consequence
consequence of this conflict
now that means i haven't specified the
direction of change but you you would do
that hoping that you could both attain
something better as a consequence of the
negotiations yeah and you can almost
inevitably
and that's what you can aim for it's
like let's make this better
not average not you know miserable in
the middle but better for both of us
that's the point of a successful
negotiation it's also
means that the negotiated agreement will
be stable
because if you have to give in
let's say and compromise well then
you're not really pursuing what you want
to pursue and so you're going to work at
a counter position to that
subtly and maybe not so suddenly but if
you see oh this is this solution that we
both generate is way better than either
of the things we were doing before
that'll just sustain itself when one
person has to trust that the other
person is going to do the same thing
right i think that's where it is because
people fight like an actual fight in a
relationship when the trust disappears
about something right yeah either you
know you assume that the other person
isn't going to be able to move past it
in some way or isn't going to be able to
apologize in a meaningful way or
whatever they were motivated in a way
that wasn't right it was untrustworthy
in some way yeah that's right
and then you know it's one person at
least has to decide that
there's a you know
a spark of trust that will come back
right in that area
yeah exactly and you don't have to think
that the other person's right or
anything you just have to think that
they are willing to
actually come to a compromise of
something yeah yeah yeah a solution and
yeah certainly i mean one of the things
that your mom and i have going for us is
that fundamentally we trust each other
like i really trust her to
do her best to do the right thing
you know and that can be
rocky on the road there but i know she's
she's working man she's working
and hopefully she feels the same about
me
and so you know we decided when we got
together i had already decided that i
was going to try to
not live by lies let's say
at that point and i'd made a concerted
effort to do that for a number of years
and when we first got together that was
part of our agreements like
no lies and i don't
i don't
i don't think your mother's ever lied to
me
so she really stuck to it man once she
said she that was what she was gonna do
she
was impressive yeah yeah it really is
it's when she commits to something she's
committed and that was so useful
especially when things got really rocky
in our lives when you were sick and when
i was sick and when she was sick
because
because we could trust each other you
weren't sick no it's just awkward what
is wrong with you
i'm not sick look at me over here we
don't have time to look at you
that sounds about right yeah yeah well i
told you that when you were i don't know
how old you were 10 something like that
when michaela got so sick i i remember
talking to you and saying look kiddo
we're
up to our neck here and
you're gonna have to
be sensible and you were
because it was cool
i almost got a tear
well
uh
my feminine temperament
my feminine goals your feminine
temperament yeah
yeah
yep
wow i'm glad i'm sitting out are they
out of the pokes for this
sit here quietly uh i guess we can i
think you were too hard on yourself
about relationships there kiddo earlier
comparing yourself with julian
that seems like a backhanded compliment
i feel like i just
i i just meant in comparison to me i
didn't i'm not hard on my i don't think
i did something
necessarily
i think i did my
there
best
some extenuating circumstances over here
yeah i'm like it just didn't turn out
yeah
well you also had good relationships in
the past it's not like you've had
terrible relationships that's not how
it's going no yeah no no it was hard
yeah so it has been hard yes anything
you're interested oh i have another
question too though okay you go first
well
uh you did the the most protracted
writing you did was your thesis
so
why did you pick the topic and what did
it do for you to write that what and
what did it teach you about writing and
yeah well when i was in my fourth year
of university i was pursuing a music
minor and
and writing my thesis i was actually
taking i think i was taking six courses
working two jobs and writing my thesis
that was too much
um but it was interesting right i mean
and one of the things that uh you know
one of the things that you always say to
people but you said to us as kids was
you know it's useful to see how far you
can you know see how much you can work
right and see where your limits are to a
certain extent and that was one of the
things that it did to me that or for me
that year was that i was i was really
going at full full capacity uh doing all
those things um
and well it was great it was
writing a thesis was definitely the most
meaningful part of my university
experience um
and i chose the thing that i did
probably because it was very interesting
to me you know to go back to uh what we
were talking about earlier about finding
a topic that compels you it's i thought
it was
um i'd been reading a lot of heidegger
because that was
part of the degree that i was doing was
focused on kind of that era of
philosophers and i found his philosophy
extremely interesting uh and then i was
also
reading terence mckenna
uh at that time you would give me a few
books that were uh about
the psychedelic experience and like
fathers do yeah that's a normal thing
and i kept seeing parallels and maybe
that was the psychedelics but
[Laughter]
but in any case uh i decided they were
really there um and
um
and so i just wanted to explore that
because i didn't feel like it had ever
been explored properly uh that
relationship between
you know a fairly mainstream i suppose
well yeah mainstream philosopher and and
kind of out there thinkers like terence
mckenna or like um
yeah the other
the other thinkers that i integrated
into that paper um and it was just yeah
we're gonna i wanted to do something
like reading list producers we are about
50 books on that so is that about ready
to go like could that paper be put up
online so people could read it it could
i'll put it in the essay app
yeah i think you should put it didn't we
decide that you're going to put in the
essay yeah but it probably needs to be
edited oh god well yeah
yeah yeah it's pretty good
uh
what is essay
julian uh essay is a writing platform
that
i've been working on for the last couple
years
that basically turns
um
dad's writing philosophy uh that he used
to teach to his students and continues
to
talk about into
uh a web app that's usable for the
average writer and makes it easier to
follow the philosophy and um and learn
to write so where did this come from you
said dad's philosophy where did sa come
from yeah so
there was this document that dad
produced
for his university students
a long time ago i don't know exactly
what it was 15 years yeah 15 years ago
um and he would give this to first year
and second year students to help them
structure their essays because most
first and second year university
students don't really know
how to write very well
and they've never been taught by someone
who knew how to write so maybe they were
taught grammar in an artificial manner
but
i looked at how i was grading essays
and then formalized it and i realized i
was grading word choice phrase choice
phrase
organization within sentences sentence
organization within paragraphs paragraph
organization within chapters and then
the impact of the whole
i thought well that's also how i edit
and so i wanted to write a practical
white writing guide not not one that
focused specifically on grammar and so
when julian and i started talking about
this first we were going to just publish
the essay guide which we did we made
that available freely online but then we
were thinking through the problem of how
to teach people to write and
the hard thing about that is that
usually people write and then
submit it for grading and that's
extremely expensive and cost and time
intensive so
yeah so basically we were
attempting to turn this document into
something that people could use and they
could improve their writing in a more
structured manner
but that it would be more natural than
reading a document and trying to
do it in that way and taking bits out of
the document and trying to integrate
that philosophy into their writing
and so
we did a number of iterations uh trying
to turn it into instead of kind of a
step-by-step guide a more kind of
contained application that would
integrate the philosophy and the tools
uh that were written in the document
into something that you could just use
and it felt natural um and as you were
writing
you could kind of integrate these
practical tools and it would just come
together and improve yeah instead of
writing in a word processor and
referring to this document we just
integrated the two so that you can
so that you can write
and focus at different levels of
analysis
with each tool and so there's a
tool that
is optimized for producing a first draft
where you just
read what you need to read and take your
notes watching what you think and maybe
thinking out loud and trying to capture
that loosely as rapidly as possible and
then there are other tools that follow
on from that
yeah yeah so basically we split it out
into the produce tool the outline tool
the rewrite tool
and reorder
and basically
structure that someone's supposed to
follow when they're using this app is
they uh they outline their essays they
decide what they're going to write about
and it doesn't have to be an essay it
could be a document it could be an email
to somebody um
and so you basically come up with your
main idea and then you break it down
into subtopics um
and
then you go to the produce tool and
that's where you're supposed to kind of
fill in your ideas in a rough way which
is what dad was talking about he's kind
of right you're not supposed to edit
you're not supposed to do anything
you're supposed to get your ideas on
paper um try to
use the research that you've done and
produce
whatever you're able to produce
a loose a loose first draft
people often try to write
a good word and a good phrase in a good
sense in a good paragraph
right during the first draft so that
when they're done drafting it once
they're finished and
the problem with that is it's actually
way more work because you can't do all
of that at once and trying to just makes
it almost impossible for you to think
what you want to do is
well first you want to ask yourself a
question that you really want to have
the answer to so you have to be
motivated and that's an important first
choice even if you're writing a
document that someone wants you to write
you have to find a handle on it that
you're compelled by and that should be
stateable in the form of a question what
question are you essaying which means
attempting to answer it should be one
you have a reason to answer and then
you break it down as julian said by the
outline well what topics or subtopics
are you going to hit outline topics are
you going to hit while walking through
this that's a preliminary plan
you know because you're going to
reorganize at the level of the outline
too and then maybe you go do your
reading or your thinking and while
you're doing that note what you're
thinking and write it down say it out
loud capture it don't edit
capture and so maybe you're aiming to
produce
one and a half or times or two times as
much written material as you'll need in
the final analysis now people don't like
doing that because they fall in love
with they write with what they write and
it's hard to do it they think but it's
way easier to just
give yourself the freedom to jot down
and note everything you're thinking
and then well then you go into the well
the next tools yeah and basically the
next tools are editing tools and so the
idea that we made that we tried to
capture in this tool is to
allow people to produce variations of
their writing and to quickly restructure
it so like variations of sentences or
paragraphs yeah variations of sentences
first and so what you'd do
if you were writing
a relatively long piece in this is you'd
go through it sentence by sentence and
we have a tool that shows you
your full documents on one side and then
a broken down version of it sentence by
sentence on the other side
and basically you can
go one by one through your sentences
produce as many variants as you want and
then see them in context to your
document okay so that's a darwinian
approach to creative thinking so because
in the darwinian evolutionary process
creatures generate variance that's
mutation and and in sexual recombination
and then the environment selects from
among those variants for the most for
the most fit
uh
the the uh particulars that are most fit
at that time so this tool it'll show you
your sentence correct me if i get this
technically wrong it'll show your
sentence you click on it'll duplicate
the sentence then you can write a
variant of that sentence you can do that
indefinitely and then what you want to
do
write shorter sentences longer sentences
shorter is usually better people can
improve their essays radically usually
by cutting the sentence length by 15
that's a good first pass attempt but you
look at all these variants
choose the variant that's better and
substitute it you do that with every
sentence that's fine-grained editing not
as fine-grained as word choice but you'd
be doing some of that at that point as
well how much can you put into this like
could you edit a book
theoretically you could edit a book um
it would help in some ways because we
have the outline tool which allows you
to quickly jump
through your document
um we've had some so what do you mean
well in the outline tool
you have written your subtopics and then
what it shows under each subtopic topic
is a truncated version of each paragraph
that you have within the subtopic and so
it'll show like
um
i don't know a five or six sentence or
not even probably a four four sentence
version
so you can quickly toggle
through your essay and so it'll get an
overview of get an overview and you can
click to scroll uh and it really allows
you to navigate a relatively long
document pretty quickly yeah likely what
would happen is if you're writing a book
you'd use it for each chapter yeah
probably and rewrite the chapters and
then maybe use a standard word processor
to move the chapters around depends on
how long the book is but for lengthy
essays even multi-part essays with
multiple subtalk topics it'll work just
fine yeah so
wow yeah
yeah yeah well you we can return to the
original
let's call it principles of writing you
remember when you're thinking about a
document
you think you build it word up but
that's or do you build it letter up
i hope not right yeah right exactly well
by by the time you write you've already
automated the letter typing process
right so but then
you have to think about the word and the
phrase in the sentence and the paragraph
and the paragraph sequence and
the subtopic sequence and
the tool is designed to help you learn
to think like that at multiple levels of
analysis and so you don't have to think
like that that's kind of the point of it
right is to break the thinking out into
software so that you naturally think
that way when you're writing yeah um and
so that's how you thought writing that's
how you write right well it was an
iterative process because
while i was grading
and then trying to teach people to write
i was thinking about well what am i
doing when i'm grading now i'd already
written a lot by then
but it wasn't until i wrote this
document that i really started to
understand this idea of multi-level
simultaneous multi-level processing
which has been very useful for other
things i've been thinking through it's
like well where's the meaning when you
read
well is it in the words the phrases the
sentences the sentence organization the
paragraphs etc i don't walk through that
again but the answer is it's all of
those simultaneously and it's even
broader than that because you might
think well the essay as a whole that's a
level of analysis but there's neat the
broadest possible level of analysis but
it's not the question you're asking is
broader level because the essay for it
to be a real product a product of your
imagination and thought that will be
useful to you practically and also
psychologically let's say it has to
address something that you regard as
important or the whole bloody exercise
is a lie and i would recommend if you're
bored by what you're writing then you
haven't you're not trying to write it
the right you're not trying to answer
the right question or you haven't
formulated the right question what do
you do though this just side note what
do you do
if you're in high school or university
and you're assigned a topic
you find an angle that makes you
interested in it you have to wrestle
with yourself to begin with maybe you
write something critical when i think
it's a rare teacher
that if you suggest something that's
similar that you are interested in
they'll say no
you know i think okay so that's a try
that maybe i think generally try to
write something you know approach your
teacher and say you know i'm actually
interested in exploring this topic if
the teacher says
you're not allowed to explore a topic
you're interested in then they're
probably not a very good writing teacher
and maybe you don't care about
how they feel about your writing
that's an important point oh that's a
good point it is a good point man it's
like don't let people mess with your
words yeah and you don't you don't lose
the you know if you do enjoy writing you
don't want to have that taken away from
you by someone who's going to put you in
a box that you don't want to be in yeah
so if you really hate the topic write
something that's subtly satirical
or over the top like you have look man
writing is hard work
it's hard just like thinking but it's
not as hard as doing neither because
then you're a mess you're anxious and
you're and you're without purpose and
goal and you're inarticulate and you're
weak you lose
and i don't mean unless you win and
someone else loses matter i mean in and
everyone loses manner and so when you
sit down to write or think you have to
be motivated and if you're not you're
not doing it right and that's writing
teachers should stress that above all
else
you know they should help their students
identify something that they can hardly
wait to write about because it's so
important to them well then you've got
the motivation and each word starts to
matter because your life depends on it
and if you think your life doesn't
depend on your words you just don't know
anything about words and so it is
definitely the case let's take a
business example if you're constantly
being re forced
forced
to write things that great against your
conscience or that you find yourself
bored to death by then it's either time
to stand up and say something and then
you should use the writing program to
figure out what you're gonna
say or it's time to get a new job in
which case you should use the writing
program to put your cv and your resume
together and maybe write yourself
something like a statement of purpose
like this is no game if writing is
thinking which it is and thinking sets
your life in order or not then you don't
let people mess with your words you want
to get them on order like soldiers and
that's partly what this writing program
is designed to help people do that's not
so much we're trying to teach people to
write we're trying to facilitate their
thought and their clarity of
communication and writing
this is another thing that isn't taught
well to students well
why should i learn to write well how
else you're going to communicate with
people as you ascend up a hierarchy of
competence
like some of the toughest guys i know
jocko willink for example knows lays
tremendous stress on literacy even as a
soldier he had to communicate
orders let's say to his to the people
that that he was in command of but he
also had to communicate up the chain of
command and if your words are well
structured and
and inspired
and properly motivated and aimed like an
arrow you're unstoppable and i don't
understand well this is so many people
are taught to write by people who don't
know how to write or why to write or how
to think and that's partly what we're
trying to address here so we hope people
will find it extremely useful it's also
like knowing how to write a good email
too even if you're not interested in
essays specifically knowing how to write
a good email can change how a company is
run
absolutely well it can change people's
lives right you need to
write an email to someone you want to
get a job from or
or a landlord to try to get them to not
increase your rent or like you know
right
councilman to try to get them to do
something that needs doing in your
neighborhood or a politician to get them
to change a law
you're going to be you're going to be
making your case in front of people
badly or well your entire life yeah and
so i don't know why we don't teach
people that this arms them well we won't
use that language right because we think
everyone should be cooperative and
yeah it's it's a complete bloody mess
but we we did decide though we've been
trying to crack the problem of
scaling education
and we have a bunch of ideas about that
and julian and i were working on a
broader online university project when i
got extremely ill and it folded back
into this writing program which turned
out in some ways to be an okay thing
because this is actually
it
hopefully it will address a very serious
issue and we could do it instead of the
other one which
yeah yeah yeah the other one was pretty
broad it was too broad
yeah better breaches why it failed
probably yeah yeah well part of the
reason it hasn't failed yet
it's just been sequenced differently
yeah fair enough so solution academy is
coming yes yes yes and we're we have
online courses and we're working with
people in the broader educational sphere
so who knows what will happen should
talk about the design a little bit
because it's quite elegant yeah sure
yeah so we spend a ton of time
building the design out i mean we did a
number of iterations at the beginning um
that were very very different
my wife's a product designer
and
i'm a front-end developer and so we're
both very concerned with ux and
making things that people can use
naturally and that feel good to use
um and so
you know a lot of people don't like to
write
and that's an issue right if we want
people to write and we want people to
learn to write better and think better
then when you
go into a new application that you have
to learn it has to be very comfortable
and so we wanted to make the design very
modern very clean
very intuitive yeah self-explanatory
right because the hallmark of good
design is that you don't have to refer
to a manual to figure out how to use
let's say the tools and and these are
different things right we're trying to
teach people to interact with a word
processor differently which is a big ask
in a way to the user right and because
well because almost everyone writes
using something right people use word or
google docs or whatever whatever you
have to make it
easier for them to write using this at
least
easier but the payoff has to be there
well that's the payoff also has to be
there but he's a more worried it's not
just a blank sheet right there's more
work you actually do have to learn to
use it yeah yeah yeah but it but
theoretically and from our experience
the tools are are worth the learning
curve and we've tried to make the
learning curve as minimal as possible
using good design well right the the
other thing we did and this is a design
element too is that
while you're using
while you're learning to use the tools
you're also learning how to go about
thinking at the same time so you're not
only learning how to use the writing
program you're learning how to think
about thinking
and that's extremely important just
knowing for example that you do
multi-level processing and that you can
edit and reconceptualize at all those
levels that's extremely useful formally
to know about how you think and why you
think so it's a nice thing about the
tools in general is that they're not
they're not specific tools to the app
right like you can you can use them in
context of the app but if you're writing
an email in you know just in your
in gmail or whatever then you can still
go through it and improve the sentences
and improve the structure of the
paragraphs and you can use the tools
that you've built and practiced using
yeah internalized yeah you can use them
wherever and you can use yeah when
you're thinking you're talking as well
you know in a sort of faster way but
they're they're generally useful things
to understand and and right so my
impression going through i kind of had
to learn to use this app in the last few
months because although i was involved
in the design to begin with when i got
sick i i forgot a lot of what the app
did and why it was produced the way it
was and so i've had to relearn it
learn how to use it over the last couple
of months and
it was very straightforward to learn but
what was what i was even happier about
was the fact that
learning to use it does not waste effort
you know if you learn a program like
photoshop
you can use photoshop
the photoshop skills you've learned on
illustrator and other adobe project
products but doesn't really
generalize
outside of that domain because because
this commands are so specific with this
you could use essay for a year and then
hypothetically never use it again
because you could you you could do one
don't tell people
[Laughter]
i think that once you use it this guy's
not in our marketing team
you'll also find it a good place to keep
track of your essays and all of that to
build an essay bank and we're going to
be that's cool that's a good idea yeah
so so we we've thought about the
well the problem of what do you do with
what you've written and that's also
relevant to something mentioned earlier
if you write an essay and your first
draft is twice as long as it needs to be
and you cut a bunch of it out keep what
you've cut in another document because
yeah i've almost never
written anything
that was wasted
it might not have been useful
precisely in the context that i wanted
it for at that moment but keeping a log
or a collection of written material
especially by topic is extremely useful
as you progress through your life and
you'll find a use for it okay it's
useful for writers it's also
you know i play music and i've done that
with songs too right you can write song
lyrics and
just write poetry or whatever you're
writing and then you can you know that's
how a lot of great songs been written
little pieces here and there of
different you know thrown away songs
that yeah
the people say that all the time but
yeah so it's not just not just for
writing but for artistic things
no genuine work is wasted
it just doesn't fit necessarily with
exactly what you're doing at the moment
but but first of all the skills you
learn while you're genuinely working
generalize and also the products if you
keep them i had a
some poems i wrote
horrible poems about children
um 15 years we don't need context for
that that's okay
when i was doing my clinical work and i
needed to blow off some steam about all
the awful things i was seeing so thank
you very much in any case
i wrote those 15 years ago it wasn't
till this year that we started working
on having them illustrated and the whole
creative whole sequence of creative
projects emerged from that so you have
to realize that when you're writing
you are literally changing your brain
so
so careful about what you write about
because that's for sure for sure like
all the way down well it depends you
want your do you want to program in
garbage because you're actually
producing automated circuits in your
brain when you write and so
if you write something you don't agree
with you can do that as an exercise to
stretch out your intellectual
imagination right and to
develop
your argument let's say on the contrary
argument as part of thinking but if you
write a bunch of lies for someone that
you don't trust to do something you
don't like that will change you in that
direction if you do that 100 times
you'll be way different than the person
you were and in you may be bored
miserable angry unhappy resentful a
motivated
tendentious inarticulate but otherwise
fine yeah
yeah don't mess with your words man
the point you made earlier i hadn't
actually thought about this i've got an
issue storing way too many google docs
and sheets and google
google has like terrible storage google
drive yeah right so
the fact that you can actually store
focus pieces of writing
that's that's pretty interesting instead
of putting all your spreadsheets and
everything in one area you could put
everything that you focus on in one area
and then look back on it yeah well
google drive is obviously great but it's
because everything is there and that you
know that comes with any losers
with a cost for sure yeah you use things
all the time there yeah yeah and that's
not something that we've solved
completely with this program but it is a
good place to store the things that
you've endeavored to write
so
cool
there's
we have what three patents pending yes
yes so that's fun you know it's it's a
it's uh so it's still stealable
that's what we're saying it's still
stealable yes
virtually everything is stealable and
the way you succeed in the market place
is
becoming getting there fairly early and
then
making a product that's better than
everyone else's and then keeping it
better if you want to rely on legal
protection even patents it'll just wear
you to a frazzle it's not i mean look
you have to keep people from stealing
your intellectual property and patent
protection and legal protection can help
but in the final analysis the way that
you remain competitive in the
marketplace is to stay
not only ahead of your competitors but
ahead of your previous product right and
so otherwise you get into this defensive
mode where you're fending everyone else
off trying to protect your thing it's
like your thing
the thing you developed in all
likelihood is alive and you should stay
on the cutting edge of its development
but it's still nice to have the patents
yeah for sure so
they're hard to enforce you have to take
them out in all sorts of different
countries you know you get tangled up
with lawyers but it's no one wants that
no one wants that
no lawyers can use our program
no i don't mean that lawyers are very
useful in their proper place
this is definitely not everywhere
yeah yeah how does that work for running
out trauma then isn't it because it's
supposed to be therapeutic but
how is it not strengthening
memories associated with trauma that's
an excellent question
and there's actually a whole research
literature on that which we drew on when
we
formulated the self-authoring program
especially the past authoring program
well
james pennebaker tested that so imagine
two theories one is just write down
everything that you can remember about
the trauma and cry and be miserable and
depressed while you do that and that's
cathartic
okay but then imagine that you write
down everything you remember around the
trauma and then you go through a process
like
you would go through with our writing
tool where you organize it and you you
reduce it and you make it clear and
comprehensible and you weave it into a
narrative and you strip the emotion out
of it while you're doing that because
you start to understand what happened
and it isn't catharsis james pennebaker
tested this so he had people write about
their traumatic experiences it usually
made them feel worse for a two-week
period afterwards but yeah six months
later they had visited the physicians
far less frequently so it's out of
tyranny into the desert
and then into the promised land right so
there's a cost that you
pay when you first confront things that
you'd rather avoid and that's obviously
because why would people avoid them if
there was no cost and you might say well
that's dangerous and
ruminating
involuntarily on traumatic experiences
doesn't help get rid of them
you have to confront them voluntarily
and then it isn't expression of emotion
that cures you it's organization of the
memories into a narrative that specifies
the causal pathway why did this happen
when it happened why did it happen to me
and then is associated with
rectification of that vulnerability and
so pennebaker tested
did people use more words indicative of
expressed emotion
or did they use more words that were
indicative of cognition and
comprehension and which of those
predicted the best outcome so like like
what understand comprehend came to know
okay
angry sad hurt upset on the other side
the more
their
written product
revealed the cognitive processing
the better the effect of the traumatic
narration and you see this
you see this when you talk to people who
have had a traumatic experience if you
if you talk to them carefully and listen
carefully as they work through it so
they want to know
exactly what happened
in detail
so that
maybe they can set up their lives so
that won't happen again so you know you
were traumatized as a child but you're a
lot easier to take advantage of in your
if you're a child now you have all those
memories about being hurt okay
as the person
comes to understand their trauma
the time it takes to recount it shrinks
dramatically yeah
and that means they've they've pulled
out the gist
right the central issues from the
experience and they can use that as a
practical guide to the future that is
exactly what you're doing by the way
when you're writing an essay
you think well it's not a trauma it's
like well if you pick a question that's
interesting to you
it's interesting because the fact that
you don't know it is a problem
and so one of the great ways to figure
out what to write about is well what
bugs you
notice that that's that involuntary
rumination that's the manifestation of
underlying complexes from a
psychoanalytic perspective so
something's on your mind poking you
bugging you it's like jiminy cricket
in in pinocchio
that is really annoying
i knew that would bug you so it was a
positive you know is it so anyways you
find you find something that bugs you
that's your problem you might say well
why should i have a problem it's like
picked you it's your problem
it's your destiny
it's something you that would compel you
to solve
it's your adventure your adventure can
be found in what bothers you and won't
go away well that's your topic man
that's your life delve into that
and use this program because people have
to figure that out it'll help you figure
that out write about things that matter
you say well my life has no meaning
nothing i write is meaningful
well you're not writing about something
that matters to you and that first step
that we talked about when you specify
the question the program says this quite
clearly
specify the question you're trying to
answer you have to want the answer you
want to be motivated to write it's like
this is a hot question for me man i'm
gonna go read some things about it
because i need to know
well that's what you want to write about
that's where you find your
find your passion to use an overworked
cliche
okay well cheers guys
cheers
yeah thank god thank god